each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available all right hello everyone today
we are hosting Dominic Barry from
mcquery University from Down
Under he is a Australian research
Council future fellow at mcquary working
on Quantum information and
Metrology um and uh um Quantum Optics uh
today he will uh tell us about progress
in Quantum hamiltonian
simulation without further Ado Dominic
Barrett okay thank you so I have two
parts to this talk and uh first part is
looking at some brand new work on um on
doing compression of trotz for
hamiltonian simulation which is actually
giving us some speed UPS which people
have been uh trying to get for a few
years unsuccessfully and then uh second
part is some slightly older work which
was just published last year but that is
on using Quantum walks for hamiltonian
simulation and that does outperform the
newer work in some ways but the your
work out performs that in other ways so
um the with this um I encourage everyone
to um ask
questions um at any time during the talk
CU um they don't want people to be just
sitting there and not understanding
things and I'd rather not get to the end
of the talk than have everyone uh be
bored okay so just for the very simple
introductory stuff the uh the so Quantum
um the computer was originally coming
from the idea of findan that you could
use quantum systems to simulate other
Quantum systems and you would just be
thinking of having some physical system
which would be encoding on a different
system in a quantum computer and then
you would be trying to have evolution in
your system in your state of your
quantum computer which would be
mirroring what the actual Evolution was
in the physical system you were trying
to simulate so essentially that's the
type of thing that we're looking at
and the uh there's two different
scenarios which people have looked at
for this first of all was the scenario
by Lloyd which was that you are given
you're looking at some system which is a
tensor product of very uh small of
relatively small system so tensor
product of cubits or um systems with
limited Dimension and then in a Quantum
systems typically the hamiltonian isn't
some
Global thing over the entire system it's
going to be a sum of interaction
hamiltonians which are just interacting
um between the two particles or two
subsystems and what you get then is you
get a hamiltonian which is a sum of
terms and then these individual terms
are things which are going to be easy to
simulate now an alternative scenario
which has been looked at is that you
have a hamiltonian which is sparse and
the idea there is that well if you had a
hamilt which is a sum of terms like this
it would automatically be sparse but
then you could imagine that you don't
have something which is given to you in
a nice form like that you have something
where if you're given a row number you
can calculate where the nonzero elements
are in that row of the Matrix but if you
um but the um you don't already know how
to actually express it as a sum and this
is essentially The Spar hamiltonian
simulation proc problem which is you can
use for more physical simulation
problems but you can also use it for
using hamiltonian simulation as a basis
for other algorithms so people have
looked at this for things like um the
heroes and Lloyd work on solving linear
systems okay so in the standard methods
um going back to um Seth Lloyd's work in
96 you have your hamiltonian which is a
sum of terms and these individual
hamiltonians the HK is a limited
Dimension interaction
hamiltonians and then for a short time
you
can uh Express the evolution like this
so it's just a product of the evolutions
under those individual hamiltonians and
then for long times you just divide it
up into R intervals and you want to
choose the r in order to make that
overall error small whereas if you just
did this on the entire time then the
error would become large for larger t
so for the sparse hamiltonian simulation
you're thinking of something like this
example here so in this example we have
no more than two elements in each column
and correspondingly in each row and of
course it's permission so you have the
um an element there corresponding to a
complex conjugate there so then um you
would be describing you would imagine
that there would be some way you could
calculate given a column number where
the nonzero elements were and what their
values were so you would describe this
by an Oracle and say that you were given
a JK for a row and column number for
example and some Ancilla State and then
it's putting the value of that Matrix
element into that Ancilla and then you
would be using that to uh try to get
your
simulation so to give you some um the
the a quick overview of various
techniques for doing this so the
original proposal by was by Aon ENT
tashar back in 2003 which was for
decomposing well that should read one
Spar hamiltonians actually there the the
decomposing the hamiltonian into uh one
Spar
hamiltonians and then um the there's
some work by me and um and Richard
cleand some other people was working on
improved decomposition techniques which
are more efficient and uh Andrew uh
child's has also improved on that
further and the other thing which we
want to improve is the scaling the
scaling of the complexity in terms of
the overall time of the simulation and
for that you can use higher order
decomposition formula rather than just a
standard Trotter formula so um so these
are
given these
arbitrary order ones were originally
given by Suzuki in the '90s and then we
were looking at applying this to the
quantum simulation paper back in
2007 yeah what is one SP or two SP oh
okay so two this is actually two Spar
because has no more than two nonzero
elements in any row or column so the one
sparse is just breaking it up so you
have just one nonzero element in any row
or
column so I
should okay so um you're breaking things
up as a su of those then yeah into a sum
that can always be done of course yes it
can always be done but if you're all
you're given is some algorith algorithm
given the row positions of things in a
given Road and it's kind of uh tricky to
do that in a coherent way and you and
you would imagine that if you have say d
nonzero elements in any column then you
could just break it up into a sum of d
one Spar hamiltonians but that turns out
to be very very tricky and we'd have no
way of doing that coherently on a
quantum computer and the best we can
actually do is a d squ and this work by
Andrew and Andrew Charles and Robin
cathari was actually breaking
hamiltonians up into order
D um the the hamiltonians but and these
hamiltonians were efficiently
simulatable but they weren't actually
one Spar so we still don't have anything
any way of systematically breaking up
into less than order d^ squ one Spar
hamiltonians what was oh the D was the
number of nonzero elements in a row or
column they take the maximum which
occurs naturally and that's how they
break yeah yeah so just looking at what
the maximum is in the original
hon okay so so hamiltonian simulation of
course is going by this formula and
there's a number of quantities which
we're going to be talking about here
so um I've already mentioned we have the
time of evolution under the hamiltonian
we also have the spareness another
important thing is the Epsilon which is
the allowable error in the
simulation so one uh the problem with a
lot of earlier algorithms was actually
they were scaling polinomial in epsilon
and ideally we'd want algorithms which
are scaling polinomial in the log of 1
over Epsilon which would allow you to do
accurate simulations far more quickly
and that's what we're actually achieving
with uh this new approach we also have
another couple of things is the uh Norm
of the hamiltonian to be simulated and
typically the norm of the hamiltonian is
pairs up with the time because you can
just rescale the hamiltonian the time to
give you the same problem and there's
you can also look at time dependent
hamiltonian which I've indicated there
and then you have the norm of the um
time derivative of the hamiltonian
becomes something important and you can
also be looking at norms of higher order
derivatives as well but I won't really
be getting into that in this talk and
there's also the dimension of the system
which I won't really be looking at
scaling in that in this talk just for
Simplicity okay so as I was saying
before the the standard methods you
always get scaling its polinomial in the
allowable error and also if you're using
these trotz approaches for time
dependent hamiltonians you get a result
that depends heavily on the derivatives
of the hamiltonian so if you have a
rapidly changing hamiltonian it's going
to be inefficient
also
SC the this is scaling of the complexity
so thinking of the really number of
Oracle calls to Hamilton so you could
actually quantify the complexity in two
things one is the number of Oracle call
the hamiltonian and the other is the
number of additional Gates and really uh
you want both want it to be efficient in
both of those
things yeah I still worried about this D
suppose you have in each column at most
three y but some rows no no this is this
is uh her Mission so if you take the
transpose complex conjugate it's the
same thing so it's always going to be
the maximum in each the same Max in the
rows as it rows as it is in the columns
that's what so you want always take the
maximum of both yeah well it's the same
same
yeah though you can also look at um a
slightly different problem which will
give you where where you are looking at
um the you can also look at things like
unitary implementation which I will have
right at the end of the this so I might
have time to talk about it but there you
have to worry about the spareness in
both
directions okay so
um yeah yeah so getting back to here we
have have a scaling which is always
superlinear in t when we do these um
trotz approaches whereas the lower
bound um is actually strictly linear
scaling in T and also this scaling as is
at best D cubed in the spareness and
that's using the scheme of Andrew and
Andrew Childs and
cathari so he um what do mean lower
bones lower bones for the there the
complexity of the
simulation so essentially it's telling
you that you can't if a system is
evolving over time T you can't simulate
the evolution of it in with complexity
that's less than linear oh yeah so and
what does it mean scaling the
best what does it mean well it's again
the scaling in the number of Oracle
calls
and yeah yeah number of
orac but what does it mean at best what
is the worst um well that worst is is
infinity if you don't have don't have an
algorithm right if I do have one uh can
it be exponential in the well we well
well if we go back to these ones ours is
going as D um D to the power of 4 plus 1
on 2K I think and uh so it's effectively
d d to the 4th and there's goes like d
cubed yeah and if you want to know what
the lower bound is then the lower bound
is actually root D which is um be
because if you can simulate if if you're
thinking of having a a um problem which
is encoding a search problem then the
lower bound on the complexity of search
means that you can't solve it in less
than root
D okay
so these are two distinct areas so this
first one is the um these things are
improved by the first um the algorith
which I'll be talking about that's the
new one and these second the pair of
things are improved by the quantum walks
approach which is in the second half of
the talk are you assuming some B of the
condition number of each
here um no we don't have any dependence
on condition number at all
okay afraid to lose you so at best means
in the worst
case T TQ is the worst case the best
which you can reach in the worst case
right essentially yes so if you have
have an artificially simple problem then
you can solve it more easily but the
only but any algorithm which is going to
be solving the uh looking at solving all
problems there's going to be at least
one problem which is going to be U order
de so I wanted to contrast the worst
case with say average case sorry with
average case because when you go well
for these types of things the average
case is actually basically the same as
the worst case and the um but a we have
a slightly different thing with the
second algorithm because with the second
algorithm we can actually prove that we
have scaling at worst as D to the
2/3 but for any realistic problem it
goes like um the virtually root D and
it's just that we can't rule out really
really pathological examples where it
would be going like d to 2/3 but this D
cubed scaling isn't like that it's like
you expect pretty much everything to be
going scaling like
that okay so this is the first algorithm
is calling this polylog hamiltonian
simulation because we get simulation
which is linear in some things in the
time for example and then it has a poly
log factor which is the um basically all
the other par parameters which I was
talking about so the the um to go into
the known results in a little bit more
detail um so our result was that it's we
can decompose the sparse hamiltonian
into order d s one Spar
hamiltonians and we have a complexity
which is so this log star is is
essentially if you're starting with n
you look at how many times you have to
take log to get down to um down to two
or three or something like that and if
you're looking at any sensible number
it's no more than no more than five or
something or so so it's you can really
imagine that that's
constant uh we can improve that to order
D um and I should have corrected this
this isn't actually one Spar
hamiltonians it's officially efficiently
simulated hamiltonians
but then there's an additional cost of
complexity linear in D and that's the
children and Kari
paper then if we look at using the
arbitrary order um product formula and
actually called L trotto Suzuki formula
we get a norm of H * t to the power of 1
+ 1 on 2 K and that K is like the order
of this product formula and then the
scaling in terms of the allowable error
is like a one on Epsilon to the one on
two K so for large K you can make this a
small power of Epsilon but you can't
make it logarithmic in one on
Epsilon uh and so this is um actually
the summarizing the result in the second
part of the talk which is that we can
use quantum walks which gives us
strictly linear scaling in the norm of
h& T but then that makes the scaling in
the error
worse then if we're looking at time
dependent hamiltonians then we get a
similar scaling as this except we now
have dependence on all the derivatives
of the hamiltonian well up to 2 K order
derivative derivatives of the
hamiltonian I think in
here just for completeness what's the
definition of the normal of each um so
if I remember correctly this is like the
two Norm so if you're thinking of a two
Norm of the state and it's multiply
applying the hamiltonian by the state
it's the largest factor by which the
norm of the state can be increased okay
or if you're looking at um ion values
it's um a square of the largest yeah
yeah I'll hang on
it Norm the max Norm of the maximum
value you don't have have a square
factor in
there okay there's various Norms so I'm
just yeah yeah but but the important
thing is that the norm is actually
linear in h so multiply that multiply H
by a constant factor and that Norm goes
up by a constant
Factor okay so then another thing is
that if we there's another algorithm
which was proposed by Dave pin and
co-workers back in 2011 which was was
was for time dependent hamiltonians
which actually managed to get rid of
entirely rid of the dependence on the
derivatives of the hamiltonian but then
it had much worse scaling in eps I think
that was on at like one on Epsilon cubed
sorry one on Epsilon squ in that case
and it also had worse scaling in the h&
T okay so for the new the uh algorithm
we have here we have scaling That's goes
like the norm of H and T which is like a
lower bound so have to at least have
that scale and we also have a D2 which
is improving on the D cubed which was
best before with um except in the case
of the quantum walk approach and then
it's poly log in everything else so the
poly log scaling in the error has never
been achieved before uh and it's also
you also have poly log dependence on the
derivative of the hamiltonian so unlike
the earlier approach which had um well
it had poor scaling in epsilon but no
dependence on the derivative we have
some dependence on the derivative but
it's only on the log of
it and the scaling in Norm of H and T is
the um linear up to the PO poly log
factor and the only time that's been
beted before is with our algorithm which
had actually worst scaling an
Epsilon okay so to give you the method
for this this is essentially based on a
trotterz so uh well first of all we want
to decompose the hamiltonian into one
spar
hamiltonians second thing to do is to
decompose those hamiltonians into a sum
with with the equal weightings of self
inverse
hamiltonians and then we can use a just
a simple lead Trotter expansion of the
evolution into a product of Evolutions
under those self- inverse
hamiltonians then we U have a method in
an earlier paper for using um using some
control cubits to turn
this trotted so this part don't worry
about so much about what this part means
I'm going to explain this in detail um
turn the Trot decomposition to
essentially discret steps at Su
superposition of times and then we're
using a method which we just have in
this recent archive paper for performing
efficient measurements on these control
cubes so don't worry too much if you
don't understand what these things mean
I'm going to explain
them okay so the first part is the
decomposition into yeah which
which which uh item here is your secret
Source uh well probably I'd say this one
because decomposing into a sum of self
inverse HT so people had looked at a few
different approaches before and um and
sort of couldn't work out how to um get
the tonian into a sum of things which
you could apply the apply the rest of
the recipe to so this this is what makes
it all
work okay so just going into the I so I
think I've probably explained most of
this before we have this Matrix for
representing the hamiltonian in this
case it has no more than two elements in
any row or
column and what you want to do is
decompose it into two well in general
you'd have to decompose it into 6D squ
Parts if you're using the general recipe
on a quantum computer but just doing it
by I you can break it into these Yellow
Part Parts and blue parts and each diff
different color um is the corresponding
to a hamiltonian which is one sparse so
it only has one element in each row or
column so then that well that's just you
can just use the scheme from the old
paper there then the next step is to
break these one Spar hamiltonians into
self inverse hamiltonians so this is
this is the um trick that makes it all
work I but what is there any guarantee
that when when can you split into two
well when I've um worked out a special
example to give in
presentations uh okay so this is this is
just for illustration I say in general
you'd have to do it into 6D s Parts
yeah okay so now I've grayed out what
was the yellow ones here in this slide
and then I'm thinking of breaking these
colored ones up further um so what
I'm
and I've oh okay so this one which is a
very light red is that is what I'm
calling the X component and um that is
essentially things which are off the
diagonal and real and if you think of
like an X poly Matrix then that's like a
ones on the cross diagonal so
essentially if you're looking at the
two-dimensional Subspace which is like
composed of the points on those row and
column numbers then this is proportional
to an
X and similarly with the um green ones
here that is things which are off
diagonal and imaginary so that is
essentially things which are
proportional to Sigma y on that Subspace
and similarly with the Zed is just
things on the diagonal so the general
idea is that we're then going to want to
say that well we if we just looked at
this one on its own then that would
would be we we could say that's like a
Min - < tk3 * an X and the x is self
inverse but the problem is that we're
not going to get things which in the
different two-dimensional subspaces
which all have the same multiplying
Factor so if you look at this for
example you have aun2 * I here and an I
here and if they were both I then they
you could just have an eye type you
could just have something self inverse
there but that rout two um makes it not
work
so just
have so this is just summarizing what
I've just said so I think I'll just skip
to the next slide so now what I'm
showing is just these two elements which
are the X ones so now what we want to do
is decompose these into uh components of
the same magnitude
ude so ideally uh in practice this
Epsilon H would be something very small
like 10^ Theus 10 or something so that
you can accurately approximate the
entries but here I'm just taking it to
be one quarter for illustration so to
get accur accuracy one quarter you break
it up into things of magnitude 2 * 1/4
or 1/2 so a minus 1/3 you can
approximate is Aus a half - a half minus
a half and then if you're thinking of
allowing things up to magnitude of two
you just did put in a plus Z so then
you're thinking of um having this part
going into a hamiltonian this part going
into another hamiltonian this Etc so
you're breaking it up further into
hamiltonians each with equal
magnitude so here I'm just thinking of
say taking the second component so then
we're just looking at a minus one2 and
these entries and you just ignore
everything else which is gray out so
then if you if you just looking at these
then you have a bit of a problem because
you have things which are minus our half
and you'd have also in general have to
have things which were plus a half in
there as well but you'd also have to
have zeros because you can't have the um
zeros to have a self inverse Matrix so
what we want to do is to break it up
further and say when whenever it's a
plus a half we set say that's a plus a
quarter plus a quarter it's a minus a
half it's a minus a quarter minus a
quarter and a zero we just match a plus
a quarter with a minus a quarter so then
we're going from two igon values to
sorry three igen values to two igen
values so we have something proportional
to a plus or minus one which is what we
need for a self inverse Matrix
so in this example I'm just say taking
the first component and say we're going
to um look at the uh one which is a
minus a quarter for these and then we
have a whole lot of rows and columns
with just zero in them so we can just
fill in with um with one quarters on the
diagonal and so then I'm indicating here
sort of the with subscripts the
hamiltonians are breaking things into
and I'm calling it a plus there to take
the first component and from the minus
component you'd take that minus quarters
on the
diagonal so then if
you then take that so that remember that
one quarter was the Epsilon H if you
take that out you have the Epsilon H
times a one Spar Matrix and so you
broken up when that Epsilon H is small
you've broken up your hamiltonian with a
good accuracy into just the sum of one
Spar matrices so so in general I mean do
you need log uh of the Precision
matrices here or
something well just three or four no no
no this xon H is going to be something
tiny yeah yeah so you're breaking it up
into an enormous number of self inverse
matrices which toally how is the
enormous is it log in one Epsilon no
it's not logging 1 overon it's going
like 1 overon that's why we need the
compression oh no yeah
lar sorry linear I mean you can't do any
kind of any kind of floting Point scheme
I mean you see what I'm saying yeah yeah
so so it turns out that the compression
scheme doesn't really work with float
with uh well we wouldn't really need
floating Point anyway but if you had
binary expansion then you would need
things which were self inverse but with
different weightings and then we have a
compression scheme which doesn't really
work in that scenario and one one of the
things we're thinking of
is that in the case I was proposing it
have to be all over the place yeah
yeah okay so now getting to the Trotter
expansion so we uh so now now just for
illustrative purposes I'm just assuming
we've broken this up into a sum of two
hamiltonians which are then going to be
self inverse or proportional to self
inverse so in general we're going to
have a Time dependent Evolution for um
the for the um the expressing
our um evolution of our Quantum State
and this T is just script T is just
indicating a Time ordering operator
which you don't really have to worry
about but you can think of that as
breaking up the time into a large number
of small time intervals where you have
Evolution under one hamiltonian under
that short time at one time TJ an
evolution under the other
hamiltonian and then in the trotz you're
basically taking a finite value of
R so then the error is then scaling like
so this in the time dependent case this
is going to be a um maximum of the norm
of H and the norm of H
Prime it's going to be a maximum of that
times the T s /
R so we would think of that well we'd
think of doing this first of all on our
uh decomposition into one Spar
hamiltonians and then um and then have a
further decomposition into the self
inverse so the idea of bounding the
complexity then is the complexity is
basically proportional to this R so if
you want to have eror no larger than
Epsilon you just swap around an Epsilon
and an r and have that the r is
proportional to Lambda t^2 Epsilon so
this is what gives you a 1 over Epsilon
scaling for standard trotz and also a
t^2
scaling
so now the next trick is that when we're
looking at things which are self inverse
then we want to um the then if it's say
epsilon H * U1 then this evolution is
I've missed out an identity here it
should be cos Theta time an identity
minus an iu1 * sin Theta so the um the
thing is that when this U1 is self
inverse you always get an expression
like this and you don't get a higher
powers of U1 because U1 squar just gets
you back to the identity and this thing
you can Implement probabilistically
using a control qbit so what you want to
do is set a control cubit in a super
position of zero and one then have a
control on that to do your U1 on your
target State and then if you have a
projective measurement which is
essentially projecting onto um with that
bra you're going to get this final state
with that Evolution under that
operator and if you're looking at having
a delta T which is small then this Thea
the Theta is actually Epsilon H time the
delta T and we're wanting to have
Epsilon H really small which means that
this state is very close to zero this
state is very close to zero and we have
an overall failure probability which is
just going like Epsilon H delta
T so if we just have one of these then
it um it almost always
works so to turn things into a
a form which I'm going to be using for
the larger scheme instead of starting
with this you can think of starting with
a zero and then having a rotation which
is uh rotating it into um the and
putting those real Parts on with the
rotation Matrix and then have a p which
is just putting a the phase part on so
so that we get this state here and
similarly you can have a rotation and
have the final detection in the zero
state
are those wonderful circuits are they
listed in that paper
or El yeah yeah so it essentially it
doesn't actually give these
one one control Cubit circuits it gives
things sort of you know for the
more actually I'm not I'm not sure now I
don't remember exactly which Figures
were in that paper but it does explain
things in detail in that paper previous
slide so you measure
01 which is good for you sorry oh it's
you measure as a superp position of 0
and one so to think of it in terms of
measuring the 01 basis you have to put
that rotation on it first mhm
y but you can so you say it's Forest you
will get that measurement all the time
yeah well if you're post selecting then
you get that measurement result but you
can't really post we have to think of
what's also going to happen if that
fails and how to go back and correct if
that fails so what what is the
probability that you get one that is
going like Epsilon H delta T so the idea
is that we're making both of these small
and we have an overall probability of
success which is reasonably good and and
if you get one then what you thr it out
no no cuz we're going to have to do a
sequence of these which means we have to
do simulation which is basically
reversing the thing and if we have a
failure we actually get like a root
square root of U1 here and that's
something that's something which we can
correct deterministically okay so we can
it's actually quite a complicated
procedure cuz you have to go back
through the entire thing and correcting
and then the you have a probability of a
quarter of your correction failing in
which case you have to correct again but
you overall have it's like a random walk
except you have a very strong waiting of
going towards a success self inverse is
important yeah yeah that's another area
where the self inverse is important and
we've actually been looking at sort of
other scenarios which um which could
potentially make things nicer in other
ways but then the correction operations
we don't really know how to do so um so
that's why we go with this approach
okay so now as I was saying before we're
looking at an overall total time of T
that we're wanting to simulate over and
we would be thinking of using a Trotter
decomposition over that entire time but
then breaking up the time into intervals
of length one quarter and it's one
quarter in this original paper but it's
going to be something slightly smaller
in our scenario and so then we called M
for the number of Trotter intervals
which we're using in this time period of
length one
quarter so then when we do that the
probability of success for the using
that controlled operation multiple times
is going to be at least three quarters
which means that with with we have a
good probability of success and if we
don't have a success then we have a good
probability of um
correction
okay so now this is illustrating what
happens if we have many control
operations so we're thinking of having
basically each of these is what I was
showing before except I've thrown out
the P's for Simplicity so in a trotz you
wouldn't have a U2 U1 U2 U1 U2 U1 Etc
are all interleaved together and then
the um we have each of these um each of
these controls on different
cubits so then if we look at what's
happening at the beginning here these
are all very tiny rotations so this was
a rotation like this where the alpha is
approximately equal to one and the B is
going like a 1/ root M and the M was the
number of these things in the which is
16 in this
diagram so then if you're looking at the
state here it's like this tens at M *
and this is like Beni trials in a superp
position and what it's going to give you
because when the more be is this is
essentially waiting that's going down
exponentially in the so this Norm of X
which I've Illustrated here this x is a
bit string and the norm of X is the
number of ones in this bit string so the
essentially the probability here is
going down exponentially in the number
of
ones so typically you're getting strings
like this where you have lots and lots
of zeros and only a few ones and so you
can think of what the positions of each
of those ones are now what I'm
illustrating here is this is actually a
multiple controlled operation on all of
these cubits and it's going looking at
all of those QQ bits and working out
where the first one is and so if you
remember before I was alternating U2 U1
U2 U1 U2 U1 Etc so what that's telling
you is that if the uh first one is even
you should be do in an even position you
should be doing a U1 if it's an odd
position you should be doing a
U2 so what these controlled operations
are doing is essentially just looking at
the parity of these control of the
position of the of the one in the
control cubits and doing a U2 or a U1
based on that and so that's what that
big vertical oval is
y so so then
the there's also a third alternative
which is that it's run off the end and
there's no more ones in that in that um
bit string in the super position in that
case it just does the
identity okay so as I was saying before
you have this strongest waiting on
having the smallest number of ones so
what I've indicated here does the whole
thing except these ones out here are
almost never going to get done so what
you can do is look at is ident ify these
later ones which are never going to be
be um they or almost never going to be
done and Adit them and the overall
circuit is still going to be accurate
accurate within the error that you need
provided the the K the the K I'm going
to use here is the number of these that
I retain provided you choose that
appropriately with Epsilon you get still
have the overall error of the procedure
properly
bounded
okay so now I'm just rearranging things
to make it a little bit neater for the
following slides uh so now what we're
doing is we're
replacing those long forms of the
control cubits with a compressed form so
what we're doing is like is we're having
different registers which are just
storing the positions of the ones so
we'd have a P1 up to P which is the
number of ones in the string and then
since we have a fixed number of
registers we just have to p out with
some um there something would just make
it an M um to pick something
definite see people pulling terrible
faces
there so it's it's a very simple
compression technique but then when you
get to do the measurement then it gets a
little bit more
difficult so essentially what we have is
we have a um so this is indicating the
compressed form of the uh control Cubit
so this three up here is the position of
the first one this is the position of
the second one this is the position of
the third one so actually what these now
yeah yeah this is encoded so actually
this control is actually only be being
controlled on these this one's only
being controlled on these and this one's
only being controlled on
these so um so first of all there's a
question of how to do this preparation
here and second is how to do the uh
final operation so if you remember
before we had all of these RS on this
state so to do the V on this we can use
something like this so um essentially
what we have is one cubit which is a
control Cubit which we have a rotation
on and then we have a whole lot of
controlled rotations on the remaining
cubits which can give us essentially
almost exactly what the state is we want
except we have some extra cleanup steps
to fix those padding so if you remember
there's these padding cubits here and we
need some extra cleanup steps to fix
those but otherwise it's um it's fairly
straightforward and you also need to so
this is going to give you relative
positions between the ones and you also
need to do some operations to get
absolute positions of the ones which is
what you need for these
controls so so what's in the oval and
what's in the v right oh this is all V
that yeah yeah this is this what this is
indicating is all V so that we can can
use this V to get absolute positions of
the ones that these used yeah so so what
are those ovs have in them talls what
are the talls have in them now okay so
this one is just actually controlled on
the top three this one's only controlled
on the so what it says is if all three
of them are one then no no no no no
the these cubits here are encoding a
position so it's like it's like um the
it's it's just the um the three cubits
encoding the position of where one was
in the previous
thing but yeah yeah I understand but but
I mean if that if that thing has one
wire coming out of it determining
whether to apply UI or not yeah right
then you have to detect identity with I
mean that UI the I has to line up with
the I on that first set of three wires
and so right
so as I varies the that unitary down at
the bottom UI will change yep yep that's
right right so I guess so what you're
saying is that the the threei values are
somehow I mean I don't understand how UI
varies with I I guess is what I'm
saying oh well it's just looking to see
if this one's odd or even for this
controlled operation this one's checking
if this one's odd or even and so forth
and I guess with when you've only got
two there you'd only be needing to
um well I guess you're needing to check
two things you need to check whether
it's odd or even or it's in the M stes
indicating that there's no more
ones so other than that it's just a nor
control operation which you can do
relatively
easily but sounds to me like the
question was what allowed you to neglect
yeah I have the same question the rest
to to neglect what sorry so I guess you
you lost you lost me anyway on on
exactly how these controls are working
and why you can eliminate mean all back
here so ah okay so the idea is that this
one is controlled of the position of the
first one but if there's no ones at all
in there you just do nothing okay then
this one's controlled in the position of
the second one but if there's no more
than one one you don't do anything there
and so if you go up to here you only do
this one if it's all ones which happens
with a ridiculously small
probability so all of basically all of
the ones you're throwing away are the
ones that are only happening with very
very tiny
probability
okay so okay so these control functions
are quite complicated but yeah yeah
relatively complicated but they have
have um gate decompositions which I
won't go into here the statistic is only
so many many ones yes say not rarely
more than K yeah when you saw K you can
ignore yeah so as I was saying that K is
selected so that the error from
discarding those strings with high Hing
weight is very
small okay so and we were talking about
how to make that state so the details of
that aren't so important because what
going to look at is how to do this
measurement which is kind of tricky
because ideally what we're wanting to do
is take these compressed
cubits and decompress them and do a
whole lot of these our rotations and as
I was saying before we want to have
measurement results of zero on
everything but we've got a probability
of a quarter of having some measurement
results of one so if we do have a
failure we need to work out where that
failure is or we can't correct it so we
have to be able to work out where the
positions of the ones are on that
measurement in the uncompressed basis
but typically there's only going to be a
small number of ones so when you get
this measurement result it's actually
something which you could compress back
down again so if you think of ideally
what we'd want to be doing is to start
with a compressed basis uncompressed do
the RS do the measurement and then
compress back down again but we're going
to from a compressed basis to a
compressed basis so surely we have some
way of going from one to the other
without expanding out to an inefficient
number of
cubits so very
large expansion should be really good
yeah yeah CU what what we
eventually doing is taking our trotterz
which is the um putting like a factor of
Epsilon in there from the trotz then
we're getting another factor of Epsilon
because we're breaking up each of the
individual hamiltonians into these tiny
Parts which are going to be proportional
to self inverse so then if then that
number of things is like going to be the
number of control cubits we have which
is going to be huge so we don't want to
be doing things in that in that
uncompressed BAS
okay so yeah so the reason why I was
going back to this slide was because
we're thinking of having things in a um
in a compressed form of zero originally
and then doing a v operation which is
taking us to the state we want and then
if we had the state we wanted here and
inverted this operation we'd get all
zeros and measuring would be giving us
all zeros but when because we have these
controlled oper operations here we've
actually changed this state because it's
now entangled with this thing so um but
if we still actually were lucky and got
the all zeros measurement we would have
performed the correct measurement that
we
wanted so we do know how to do a
measurement that succeeds but as I was
saying we don't always have a
measurement that succeeds if it doesn't
succeed we need to know where it's
failed so the um is so to explain this
first of all what we can look at
is doing a partially non-destructive
measurement so we're thinking of instead
of just measuring in the compressed
basis um what all of these individual
bit values are we can say we're going to
measure it as all zeros or everything
that's orthogonal to all zeros so it's
something in this plane here and you can
think of doing it with this type of
controlled operation here so this is
just some exra in a state one if all of
these things are all zeros and that
flips this to a zero and you measure a
zero here whereas if anything is a one
here oh sorry um no no that's right yeah
yeah so so and then if uh then if
anything is a one here this doesn't get
flipped and it comes out as a one yeah
so now in the following diagrams it's
going to be shown by this oblong here
and so we have a recursive measurement
which we want to do which looks
something like this so we're essentially
taking the entire thing and doing this
projective measurement between all zeros
and everything orthogonal here and if
you assume that you find it's not you
then divide it into two and you're
keeping on doing it like this on the
first one not succeeding yeah yeah so if
it does succeed you don't go any further
controls so so like the the the way it's
happening here is it's going to a one
here and a one here so at this stage you
found at least one one then here you're
finding that you have a a at least one
one in this half which is ends up being
this one this one you find at least one
one in this half which turns out to be
this one and then at this stage this one
finds all zeros so these are all grayed
out because you don't actually need to
do any further
operations and similarly there and in
this way you end up finding all your
ones without having to go out of a fully
compressed basis and what you find is
that the complexity of this
uh the
um the number of measurements steps that
you need if you're actually finding uh K
ones out here is going like K * log
M so essentially log m is number of
times you have to divide in two and you
have k for um the having to find that
one and having to find that
one so essentially it's still efficient
because you don't have anything that's
going linearly in in M
there so how am I going for time so I
have a bit
more explanation of how this goes which
perhaps Isn't So Illuminating
um so we have to be thinking
about thinking about uh having to
actually do things not just in that
original basis we have to do that
operation which is inverting that
preparation and then are redoing it
after the measurement and then we have
to break things
up of the the
uh then we have to have an operation
which is breaking up the compression
into the two halves
but I'll just skip over that so just
bringing all of these details together
what we end up doing is dividing so
about case steps you're ready to make a
correction at the end you do make well
well well if you if you're thinking of
what happens after all of those
measurements you all you've done is
located the value the positions of the
errors and then you have to go back and
make a compression sorry a correction
but the correction is basically as
difficult as doing a simulation you
gotun simulation backwards yeah you got
to run it backwards and and put
Corrections for those individual errors
in that backwards simulation yeah and
and how many ARS uh it goes uh if it
goes according to laws of probabilities
for random
walks so you have an exponentially small
eror room of needing more than some
fixed number of of iterations of the
that's where the ROMs so so when you go
to like to fully quantify the complexity
you have to look at sort of how many
errors it's having to correct and how
many steps it's having to go backwards
to actually do the full correction and
the the length of the the walk and so
forth but it all turns out that since
it's so heavily biased toward success
and everything uh is nicely
bounded
okay so this is the uh where we bring
bring all of these parts together so we
had uh first of all a division of the
hamiltonian into this number of parts so
we originally had a d squar or 6D s for
the original decomposition we just throw
away the six for the order scaling and
then we have a norm of H on an Epsilon H
to get accuracy Epsilon H for this
approxim
and that's just because um and I I
actually put a Max Norm of H in here for
the paper because essentially you're
just looking at the maximum absolute
value of an entry in The Matrix and then
you might need to break that up into
order um a Max Norm of H parts to get
down to order one and then another one
on Epsilon H parts to get down to size
Epsilon h so then we are act if you
remember before I said we were using
time segments of length one quarter and
the idea of the time segments in the
original um 2009 paper was to get
probability of success of three qus now
we actually need to subdivide it into
their parts of length proportional to 1
on M * Epsilon H and we have the order
this number of parts now it might seem
nasty that it has a one on Epsilon H
there um but it comes in the product M *
Epsilon H and M was divided by Epsilon H
in the first place so that actually gets
rid of a factor of Epsilon
H which is something that we need
because the um so we have this number of
segments and essentially what the
scaling is coming from is that we have
this number of segments and each of
these segments we can do with complexity
that's essentially poly log and all the
other things so then when we look at the
overall complexity we get this thing
coming down here times the poly log
factor and this poly log factor is
coming from that compression and then
just multiplying this m * Epsilon H
gives us a d^2 norm of H which is coming
here and then the time just comes down
there so that's where our overall
scaling for the algorithm comes together
it comes
from okay so that was part one for that
simulation this is part two which is the
um the which is just as
easy okay so uh this is using Quantum
walks for simulation which is strictly
linear in the evolution
time uh so these three ingredients to
this uh one of these is what's called
The Zed Quantum work so um so I'll need
to explain a bit about what Quantum
walks are first I think and then we use
a coherent phase estimation which is a
bit like a kave phase estimation and
then we also need to use a controlled
State
preparation so the general idea is that
this Quantum w
it's it's going to be essentially
operating on the state in some expanded
space and it quantum walk is going to
have igen values and igen vectors which
are related to the igen values and IG
vectors of the
hamiltonian so there's a general
procedure where if you have one
operation which you can do and another
operation which you want to do and the
IG values and IG vectors are related in
a nice way you can do phase estimation
to work out what the en values are and
then artificially put on the en values
that you want for the state for the
operation that you want to
perform so Quantum work is a unary
transformation yeah yeah so um I you
should have slides if I've explaining
this in more detail so the normal
Quantum W you have what you call a
position oper a position um subsystem
and a coin subsystem system so
essentially the coin is just a cubit and
the position is like some the um like
integers so if if you think of what a
walk is doing you you actually have a
coin flip operator which would be like a
hadam mod and then um and then so so
essentially if you're starting on a plus
or minus one you're getting a plus or
minus in this thing and that coin
operator isn't affecting the X
and then the step operator is looking at
the value of the coin and it's doing a
plus one or a minus one on the position
depending on the value of the coin so if
you think of What's Happen what that's
doing you can start in the zero position
and if you just had a classical walk
you'd randomly do a step from to the
left or the right and you'd get
essentially a um Gan distribution
approximately and the width of that is
going out like the square root of the
number of steps but when you do a
Quantum walk you have actually
amplitudes for going out to a distance
which is linear in the number of steps
and sort of this was sort of an original
motivation that people had for thinking
that Quantum walks might give you
computational speedups and there was
some um very clever work with sort of
doing Quantum walks on more complicated
graphs rather than just in lines which
give interesting speed ups but I won't
go into that uh what we're using is
what's called a zed Quantum walk which
uses um more General operations which
should we call um controlled diffusion
operations
so to explain what these are doing these
are a rather strange thing so I'm not
not sure if You' be familiar with this
type of thing is this is essentially
giving you a um
reflection
and these are controlled Reflections and
the first is controlled by the F first
register and acts on the second register
so before we had a position in a coin
register now we have two registers which
are basically symmetric between each
other and the second one is essentially
the opposite of this it's controlled on
the second register and acts on and acts
on the first
register so then what these are doing is
so the C you take some general Matrix CI
J and you have these states which are
expressed in terms of the square roots
of the entries of that Matrix and then
what this C is is that's a the um a a
projector on I on the first system and
this it's a state CI on the second
system so it's like a a controlled State
preparation so then what happens when
you construct this thing is that so the
uh essentially what it does is it
takes this operation is looking at the
value of I on the first register and
based on that register it reflects
around CI in the second
register okay so then the uh we have a
similar definition for the for the r and
the quantum walk is just alternately
doing these two steps so what we want to
do is look at the igen values and IG
vectors of this step operator and it
turns out that those IG values and IG
vectors are related to a matrix which
you can form from the C Matrix and the r
Matrix so the idea now is to use a
symmetric system so the dimensions of
the the um of the two things are the
same and these cnrs are just the complex
conjugate of the entries of the
hamiltonian now the igen values and IG
vectors of the war are going to be
related to those of the hamiltonian
which I the um I don't think I've given
the formula for just because it's not
very illustrative but um but uh the
thing which is fairly important for this
is we need to modify this state
preparation so you remember before we
had this state preparation to this state
so remember this was then going to be
complex conjugate of hi J so if we had
just did the same thing we'd just be
having this part but that wouldn't
actually be a normalized state with this
hamiltonian so you can think of putting
this multiplying factor in and if you
just that I can't see sorry so so this
this if you just ignore this Delta for
the moment if you have a one on the one
um actually
um yeah I think you'd actually have to
have a one on root Sigma I there to make
sure that that thing's normalized but
then the sigma are dependent on the
value of I which would mean that you'd
have to have a i dependent thing out
here which is not what you want you want
to have um just a constant here so to
make sure that the entire thing is
normalized you have to have this extra
part out
here and then you have an overall superp
position which is just um controlled by
those Matrix elements of the
hamiltonian and there's a couple of
difficulties here which is that well
this Sigma is not something which we
know how to
calculate and
and
um well that's the main difficulty and
another thing which you'll notice here
is I've put in a Delta there rather than
a one and the reason is that we can make
this Delta small if we make this Delta
small then this thing becomes small and
it's mostly weight on a single state and
this means that when we do a step of the
quantum walk it's actually very close to
the is quite close to the
identity and this might seem like a
counterproductive thing to do but it
turns out to make things quite
nice so call this the the laziness
parameter so and as I was saying this
thing's unknown which is a problem and
so the three-step process we have for
this segy Quantum walk approach so this
is due to Andrew child's back in 2009 is
to start with the state in one of the
subsystems so this is the state we want
to simulate the hamiltonian on and
perform controlled State preparation so
that we have a joint State across both
registers now we have this Zed Quantum
work which we can then do over these two
registers and then that approximates the
hamiltonian evolution and then at the
end you can invert the controlled State
preparation which it gives you an
approximation of the desired final state
in just one of the Reg
and the idea in step two is that you can
do it with that small Delta that um that
laziness parameter and you can
essentially just do things as in that um
as in that procedure but you can also
use this phase estimation approach which
I was mentioning
before it's more like increase parameter
than plac because you want it small
what parameter to eagerness eagerness
eagerness because when it's small it's
lazy oh yeah I guess so um I see I seem
to remember as a draft who called it an
un laziness parameter or
something okay
so cuz that's because Andrew was using
the previous war war which was defined
by seed but seed didn't use it for
hamiltonian simulation and Andrew's IDE
and other things equivalents with with
coins for for the walks so and people
built the page rank stuff on top of that
for his other things oh okay
yeah we have that up and writing
actually um so now this is explaining
how this simulation by phase estimation
works so this is for sort of a general
very general procedure where you want to
implement one unit uh where you can
Implement a unitary V which in this case
would be the step of the Walk but you
want to implement a different operation
o and in our case this o is still a
unitary but you can also think of doing
this for non-unitary things which is um
the what what for example harass and
Lloyd um linear systems work does so now
the idea is if these operations share
igon States but the igen values are
related by a function then this is
something very useful so here you say
get a e to the I Lambda where the
lambdas are real for I values of this V
then you want to put in an F of Lambda
here now you can implement this unitary
V many times and perform phase
estimation in a coherent way just by
using a k of style phase estimation and
then what that gives you
is this P gives then has an extra
register where you put an estimate of
the um of this Lambda which you're using
to index these values and en
States so then what you can and and this
um side Lambda is just the individual
weightings in the original
state and then you your F of Lambda is
something which can be imposed and if
this is a unitary then the F of Lambda
is just a phase factor which you can do
deterministically and you can do
non-unitary things if you are allowing
yourself some probability of error as
well
so um and you have a little bit of
difficulty because this isn't
necessarily an exact estimate so you
have some error due to that but ignoring
that all you're getting is you're
getting this F of Lambda factor in the
superp position so then when you invert
the phase estimation you wipe out that
thing and just get this and this is what
you'd want if you were just performing
the operation o on your initial
state
okay so in our case what the V is is
it's the step of the walk and the O is
the evolution under for some
time and the idea okay so this is where
I give the the um igon values so the if
you have a igon value mu for the
hamiltonian then the step of the quantum
walk has ion values like this so you
actually get a plus or minus E to the
plus or minus I sign Mu Delta
and the operation o would be Evolution
on the hamiltonian so you want to
actually put those igen values in there
and you can um it's a little bit more
complicated than the case I just
explained because you also have these
Plus or minuses so a single I Vector for
the hamiltonian goes to actually two
igon vectors for the uh step of the
quantum walk but you can actually work
out which one it is and doesn't really
affect the analysis much
so we have a range of new advances so um
some of these are going Beyond just
hamiltonian simulation so what we do is
actually combine the lazy Quantum walk
with phase estimation which improves the
efficiency and we also have a procedure
to achieve the controlled State
preparation and we can then combine that
with
trotz and with that is what would give
you
the root d scaling and another thing we
can we've looked at is applying this to
unitary operations which is quite
interesting because if you look at a
nonsparse case you can actually apply
this to non-sparse cases as well you can
say um if you're given a dimension n
unitary then it's got n byn n * n
entries in there and normally if you're
doing a decomposition of this thing into
Gates then you're going going to need
complexity at least n s there to do your
operation but if you think in this
Oracle type of formalism where you're
given where you they ask for a value of
the unit Tree in some location and you
have the um the Oracle can give you that
and that's the just representing some
calculation you can do then you can
Implement that unit Tre with complexity
root n in most cases which is kind of
surprising and that's where it that
result I mentioned before where we can
only prove routine in typical cases and
not in possibly the um the the um
extreme cases which give us um
problems
so I've got 10 minutes left there I
think so I won't explain everything but
I'll it just explain uh part of it so we
have steps of the quantum walk giving us
igen values like this so if we're
thinking of Mu Delta being a rotation on
the circle then we have um
actual rotations giving the actual ion
values given to us by the quantum walk
which going like arine Mu Delta here and
a pi minus arine Mu Delta here and and
if you remember before we had a little
bit of problem between these plus and
minus but because these things are so
far apart and this Delta is small and
these things we can very easily
distinguish so then if you were um
using so so if if we were just using a
lazy Quantum walk then we could
basically just say that the arc sign was
close to so linear and approximate the
AR sign by mu um Mu Delta by Mu Delta
which is just approximating this thing
by this thing here which is uh quite
close and that's what happens in the
lazy Quantum walk and then the error in
your lazy Quantum walk is just
proportional to the nonlinearity in that
arc sign but if you also use phase
estimation you can get an approximation
of that Mu Delta and just use that to
work out an approximation of that
correction you want there and because
that's a small thing in the first place
and it has a small error that gives you
a quite a Improvement and that gives you
a better result than just you you could
alternatively estimate Mu Delta and then
uh uh they well estimate this from the
phase estimation and then do the AR do
the sign rather to get the Mu Delta but
if you did that you'd get um a worse
result than combining your lazy walk and
the phase
estimation so the second thing which I
mentioned is this idea of so remember
what we were wanting to do is
essentially controlled Reflections and
you can do these controlled Reflections
if you're able to do a state preparation
now State preparation this is this is
like State preparation with an Oracle
and if you go to a paper back in 000 by
Grover he looked at this problem and and
the idea is that you're starting with a
equal superposition state with some
Ancilla and if you rotate the Ancilla
according to the amplitude for the state
which you can do if you're given an
oracle then you can get an amplitude P K
on the zero here and if you were able to
measure it and get rid of this one
component then you'd have exactly the
right waiting for the state you wanted
and that you wanted a sum over p k *
K so you can also um use amplitude
amplification which gives you a better
result so I won't go into the amplitude
amplification because that's little bit
complicated but the um I'll just compare
what we have here what we have here is
like this and the state we wanted to
prepare was like this so you remember I
was saying we were using a a um small
value of delta so this thing is small um
and then this thing is large and here as
well this thing is going to be large
because that's taking the weight of all
the
other um parts of the static B other
than the K part so the um and then this
thing is essentially corresponding to
this thing and the um the Insight that
we use is essentially that we can take
this second term in the grover
preparation to take the role of this
laziness term in the laziness in the
lazy Quantum walk and that actually
enables us to get um very
efficient um simulations in terms of the
norm of H and T and it also means that
we don't need to know this Sigma
I remember before we have this Sigma I
here which we don't know how well we
can't efficiently calculate just from an
individual entry of the H of the
hamiltonian but we don't have to
calculate it because we can just use
this
approach so then what we get is we get
um actually it's the um the you're going
to be looking at the maximum of these
two things so uh so what you have here
is you have a norm of H * T over root
Epsilon and the root
Epsilon is coming from the that
Improvement in the combining the lazy
Quantum walk in the phase estimation
otherwise it' be 1/
Epsilon and you can if that is actually
small then you have or the SP spareness
parameter is large then you have to look
at this thing so in this thing the
dependence on Epsilon has actually
disappeared altogether apart from having
to have this be larger than this and you
have a linear scaling in that in that
spareness
parameter so that is actually giving us
strictly linear scaling in the norm of
h&t and um and improved scaling in the
spareness so um as I was that that
scaling the spareness is even better
than the scaling the spareness for the
compressed approach I was explaining
first
so um if you do a alternative approach
with uh nonsparse cases and I think um
actually I've seem to have switched from
a lowercase D to a capital D
there um you can get an alternative
bound which actually looks like this
which is kind of a weird expression but
if you think um so this is actually
worse scaling in the time because it's
now to the power of 3 on two but you've
got a root D factor in there but the
other problem is that you actually don't
have just all the same Norm in here you
have a product of three different Norms
of H now if these were just going like
the the spectral Norm which is this one
then you'd just have the spectral Norm
of H * T to the^ of 3 over2 and you'd
have a nice root D in there but the
problem is that we have a one Norm in
here and one Norms can be big and the
worst case is that so so this would be
if you had
a if you had a the hamiltonian with all
entries which were about the same
magnitude then you would have a one Norm
of H which would be going like root D
time the norm of H so that H Max of
infinity Norm of H that's just taking
maximum absolute value of H so
absolutely
yeah yeah okay so that's what it is yeah
yeah obviously Infinity is a maximum no
no no I mean it's the no subscripted Max
because it's the maximum absolute value
of NRI yeah the way yeah I
mean right it's okay okay not not
because Infinity is a maximum anyway um
all all it really matters is sort of the
relations between these things so if you
think of um um the so so typically this
H Max is going to be smaller than the
than the um the spectral Norm but if you
have some row that has a um so just
assume that the spectral Norm is one for
Simplicity if you have one row that has
a one one in one entry and all the rest
zeros then the H Max is going to be
equal to the spectral Norm if you have
the opposite case which is that you have
all entries which are equal then this
thing is going to be going like root D
times the spectral Norm but in that case
the this Norm would be one on root D so
in that case you'd have this product
would actually be still be proportional
to the spectral norm and if you had a
the other case where you had one one and
the rest zeros it would still be
proportional to spectral norm and in
either case you get this scaling here
scaling like root
D but you can also have a worst case
scenario where the one Norm is going
like the root D time the norm of H and
the max Norm is just going like Norm of
H as well and that gives you a d 34s
scaling so um so you might ask where
that the
um the where that the um Improvement in
D comes from
so the
uh so now we're just replacing the D
with n because we're thinking of the
nonsparse case and the the first two
advances are allowing us to get to
routin in many cases but not all and
Thea cases where that fails are where
the non-zero elements are no sorry the
cases where this works are where the
non-zero elements are of comparable size
so if you have say m of these elements
are all about the same size and the
height of these are all going to be
about one on root M I've just taken the
norm of H to be one for Simplicity sorry
the spectral Norm of H to be
one and in that case you get that
scaling and this thing turns into
something with a root n in there and you
have a norm of H * t^ 3 on 2
yeah does
UR well if you think of for example a
um see something which is doing a Furia
transform so if you're doing um well if
you're encoding a a unit Tre in a
hamiltonian you have a fuor transform
Hamilton um unit Tre then it's just
going to be like that because you have a
lot of elements of equal size and if you
have something which is one sparse and
just has ones and the entries and that's
also going to do the same
thing
so but so the idea to get better um
simulation is to actually break this
thing up into components of equal
magnitude so in this case you wouldn't
really need to break it up but I'm just
indicating indicating this for um
indicating this to show you what um what
you do in the general case so you have
an H1 case which is all the biggest
elements you have an HL case which is
all the smallest elements and then you
would break it up into a whole lot of
intermediate chunks as well so now the
idea is if you breaking it up into
hamiltonians where the nonzero elements
are all about the same magnitude then
you get this proportionality working for
each of those hamiltonians on their own
and then you can join this up in a
trotor isation which and I won't go into
the details but um I think I'll just
skip to the end actually because we're
out of
time
so um so anyway the with that approach
which I was just explaining we can
essentially get things down to routin in
most cases but there are certain
pathological cases where you can break
things up into break the hamiltonian up
into components with about equal sizes
and you are going to get the one Norm
blowing up and becoming much larger and
when we do simulations we find that that
basically never happens but you can
construct very artificial examples where
it does
happen anyway so the conclusions of the
overall talk is this is the conclusions
for the first part is essentially that
the first scheme gives us hamiltonian
simulation with this type of complexity
where we have a D2 Norm of H and T and
rest poly log
and which is providing polylog scaling
in both the error and the derivative of
the hamiltonian which is quite nice and
then the quantum walk approach gives us
even better scaling in the D and the H
and the T though it's going to give us
worse scaling in the Epsilon and you can
also have a tradeoff to have better
scaling in some quantities and worse
scaling in the
Epsilon so anyway that's the end of the
talk so thank
you
I still I I'll talk to you later I I I
don't understand why you're penalizing
yourself for the fast decomposition
algorithm that is why you have D squ in
there we can talk about it I mean um
that's just because you have to
break yeah well you have to break it up
into D squ Parts in the first place well
but you could break it up into D Parts
with more work yeah but the that would
require actually going through by hand
and you don't have any well you don't
have to go through by hand there
actually is an algorithm to do it but
but Al the question should you should
you have to count the complexity of the
opposition AR that's my question you do
okay cuz if I just give you the
hamiltoni of that form or I do it
classically yeah I mean it's a classical
algorithm
um okay so any if you if you if you sort
of have to to break it up you have to
sort of seek a whole lot of elements of
your hiltonium that's putting a
multiplying Factor on your complexity
already so if you count it yeah yeah if
I gave you the
hamiltonian if you gave me the
hamiltonian in a already in a sum of
deep Parts supp I gave you two you in a
one sparse form yeah yeah or if it was
in a one Spar form yeah but we don't
want to be having to rely on one SP in
general
whatever okay so the sort of the
motivation for this is doing things like
if for example we want to simulate some
sparse sparse system of linear equations
and the um and the uh how to solve that
or if we have some other algorithm I was
once involved in a computer project that
could only dereference permutations in
memory
okay uh essentially it was required one
sparse loads uh it was an array machine
it would it could fetch a whole array at
once but it had to be a permutation of
the Ros of colls it had to be one spot
and uh it was very fast if you could
guarantee that so and you can
okay any other questions to Dominque
uhuh did anyone understand the second
part of the talk
good imp STI I've Implement STI so oh
okay so I'm familiar with the work good
uh I was a little little bit worried
that the question sort of peted out at
the end well the the problem is it's not
it's not a random walk it's a Quantum
walk means it's
deterministic which means that you have
to start in a fairly good overlap of the
final State you're looking for at the
preparation level to actually ever get
there
okay and the problem is the preparation
doesn't guarantee you will ever get to
the answer you're actually looking for
even though you're in a reasonable
preparation unless you you know now one
way is to adiabatically evolve the
preparation into something that at least
has a 50% overlap with the final State
and then you can use the techniques for
walking it's an alternative technique
called Quantum stochastic walks that
supposedly fixes this by adding noise
really and so you really are doing a
random walk at that point but I haven't
implemented it or read the papers well
enough to know if how well it works okay
it's going to work worse in terms of the
average conver sounds like a totally
different application to this though
yeah but that's the problem with most of
the quantum walk papers when you start
for instance the page rank ones that
were done if you do a big enough graph
you'll never get the right answers you
can't prepare because you can't prepare
it close enough the small graphs all
work because they're all overlapping
with the final States any
okay and so same problem also with
quantum chemistry is unless you know how
to prepare the initial state to be close
to a a ground state you never find the
ground state MH yeah so you know if you
know the answer you can get the answer
well that doesn't help much so yeah a
lot of this has that problem not your
stuff I'm talking about the the
underlying approaches there's a lot of
problems speeding them up is a good
thing but we also need to prepare better
as part of the problem
yeah so in general you use this for the
like the application of the in
simulation and the
par well that's one application another
application
is if you're looking at the work on
Nanda tree simulation so you have a
method of doing nry simulation which is
basically doing Evolution under
hamiltonian and if you do that
simulation of evolution under the
hamiltonian using a um using a
hamiltonian simulation approach you
basically can turn into discrete queries
whereas if it's just a continuous
hamiltonian simulation it's really
requiring uh continuous queries to an
oracle which isn't uh isn't really so
realistic and uh and also if you're
thinking of say trying to simulate
differential equations on a quantum
computer you can put on top of the Ares
of En void
approach any more
questions thank you Dominic
for